hello reject nation I'm Greg Alva and
I'm John every parent's worst sing-along
nightmare is back today haunt your dream
just imagine every mom and dad on the
road let it go
see what you're doing I see what you're
doing listen kids I want all the
children in the world to follow us I
shouldn't talk to children directly the
Stardust app it's free to download free
to use 30 second reaction reviews films
TV shows trailers or probably love for
frozen 2 as well John I challenge you to
do a singing Stardust revue after we're
done
make it happen he's gonna spend two
hours writing and composing it's gonna
be a blast these things quite seriously
so you guys follow us there yeah huge
frozen fan part of the fandom all about
it seen it so many times
Oh more than that one time I watched it
the Olaf Adventure is my favorite part
Coco best part of Coco it was not
annoying let's do this
yeah
whoa Wow
so dark I see through his shoes up got a
water
[Music]
[Music]
whoa damn I have chills I don't want to
say where but I do to have me nowhere
[Applause]
but I was Aquaman I'd say that's badass
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
is this gonna be this serious today Wow
[Music]
raisin hi
[Music]
somebody got their throat slit just then
first-person POV the skin what's R it's
the camera lens now they're gonna do
like a hardcore Henry thing with frozen
- I know it's a teaser trailer so I
don't suspect this movie will be as
serious it's feeling a little bit more
like a Pixar movie meets a little bit of
like the tone of having to train your
dragon' now more than the the prior one
did yeah I don't really
I saw the first one one time in theaters
had a great time at the time I saw and
you know I've seen all the marketing for
yeah cuz IMDB doesn't really give you
much to go off of they haven't really
told you like the IMDB all it says is
Elsa Anna Kristoff and Olaf are going
farm the forest and other truth about an
ancient mystery of their kingdom and the
town of this is seems so much more
serious and life-threatening yeah it's
like there's a lot at stake here yeah
stakes are happening feels very gripping
and then you know you're getting all
your returning characters here which is
probably the main thing you'd want to do
when doing your teaser trailer as well
as the main bit of information we have
is the tone will be slightly different
and all the characters you're used to
her back and hey here's one character
you don't recognize yet because it was
that like little girl or whatever who's
not either or else arrives well you know
the peril certainly looks a lot more
felt this time around
oh yeah well in the animation looks
insane like every time they come back
with a new movie one of the fun parts is
going wow I didn't know that computer
animation could progress this much but
like the fog at the beginning the the
water yeah of the ocean and stuff the
ice shards is there cracks I love that
opening sequence yeah so cool yeah and
you know in a way I mean this seems like
a calculated measure because I think
they know a lot of people kind of got
sick of some of the vibes from frozen
just hearing yeah let it go played out
so much Olaf played outside
so this is they gripped me in a way I
wasn't expecting yeah because the
instrument the composed music is none of
the singalong songs you know
yeah there's hinting at it yeah yeah
exactly yeah because the composer yes it
felt like very epic and I actually liked
that vibe to it
I don't know how everyone else is gonna
respond to this because I mean first to
see sure you know there's gonna be a lot
of the comedy and there's probably gonna
be just it's probably gonna be wacky in
the way the first one was also kind of
wacky yeah I mean the first one has both
a light side and a pretty like ah things
were getting heavy an intense side and
you know who that little girl is she's
maybe she's a key to the ancient history
of their Kingdom or something because
like Lord of the Rings yeah I know it's
and we'll see how do my way far out of
them maybe you know I'm curious because
I feel like the flagship Disney Princess
movies I associate sequels to those with
being a thing you've got many years
later straight-to-video so yeah now to
have this kind of scale where this is
clearly a flagship movie for them but
it's the sequel to a very beloved
musical that they've made like I'm
curious as to what they're gonna do with
that and how they're gonna make calibre
well yeah well if they're teasing with
this first sequence of her going through
the water I'm kind of curious because I
felt like from the first one her powers
were a little bit unclear in terms of
like certain limits or what maximum
capacity which and it looked like she
was having a struggle trying to master
this and I'm wondering sort of what
she's actually going for here they're
gonna why she's trying to master it yeah
I I have no idea what's what's really
happening well maybe that's the key
maybe they have to cross the ocean or
something and she's like well I can want
to make sense I kind of feel like Disney
decided to drop this because of that
wonderful reception there Aladdin
trailer god I would not at all be
surprised by that
like they definitely want to change the
narrative because Oh Goro Jeanie is not
getting great response they don't do
enough live action I mean they're doing
a plenty of live-action adaptations out
dude another animation don't worry in
ten years frozen we'll get a live-action
adaptation too okay I feel like brother
if frozen have been made twenty ten to
twenty years ago you know we would have
the live-action version today you know
every once in a while when there's
sequels that take a long time to come
out you're like oh is it gonna do well
is it really gonna do it when you have
like spin-offs and a bunch of like
marketing crap in between you like the
lego movie for example they wanted to or
you've seen it with Disney before as
well and I'm Incredibles to was it was a
major fleet in a major box-office
success for Disney Pixar this to me is
one of those things were like yeah it's
been a quite a while since the first
frozen movie came out but I could see it
doing better numbers in the first frozen
movie you know you see to me this is
like an appropriate amount of time to
wait I don't remember exactly when the
first frozen came out is like four or
five years ago right ten years ago I
don't know to me it's kind of
appropriate partly because it doesn't
feel as long because they've bludgeoned
us with so much frozen stuff over yeah I
don't know this is getting to the point
where I'm finally like okay I could
probably do this again at full length
and not be annoyed by cuz like I said I
like the first frozen it just got so
played out for me that I kind of got
aggravated over time maybe there'll be
messages about global warming and that's
what's going on with the ocean there at
the beginning of this movie you know or
maybe that yeah maybe this is a you know
some kind of crossover and then they'll
have the trench people from Aquaman you
know maybe that's why it looks so
menacing and maybe together they're
gonna be like the humans keep wrecking
everything I mean you gotta admit that
water look very real yeah oh the water
the mist through the trees like the the
leaves and stuff just the colors like
the animation is insane well before we
wrap this up guys I do want to give a
patron of the day shout out to a lovely
woman who was like the ELSA of our
Channel
Victoria Huntley she's engaged she has a
fiance and I figured with Valentine's
Day mañana I wanted to give you a page
from the day shot today I hope tomorrow
you can go make sweet kisses with your
man I can't get too dirty here because
you know kids and all that but please
make love with your man hardcore as much
as possible and by love I mean holding
hands and maybe a kiss on the cheek and
I found us that they're gonna go have
some Chinese food because her favorite
food is Chinese
she is not Chinese some glad we got
white people after all for diversity
just like this frozen cast is looking
like definitely all those Scandinavian
folks and I found out her own name
Wilson means victory and conquer
Victoria and her last name means being a
hunter just like these chicks and frozen
you're perfect to shout this out love
you Victoria guys you can subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification bow and download a false on
the star does that yay